[Music]
was Marilyn Monroe's real life not
interesting enough why else would the
makers of blonde and vent details about
her real father a polyamorous Triad and
her affair with a president
the film attributes much of Marilyn
Monroe's inner torment professional
ambition and dysfunctional relationships
to an obsessive search for the father
she never knew early on her mother
Gladys shows a young Norma Jean
Mortensen a framed photograph of a
dashing older man this man is her father
Gladys tells her a powerful man in the
movie business but whose name she can
never tell
return to Los Angeles to claim you
Monroe will spend the rest of her life
seeking him out at the height of her
stardom she begins to receive letters
from A man claiming to be her father and
the cruel revelation of the Letter's
true author is the push that sets Monroe
toward taking her own life while it's
true that Monroe was raised without a
father in real life she strongly
suspected her father was a man named
Charles Stanley Gifford whom Gladys had
an affair with while working as a film
editor at RKO pictures in 1952 Monroe
even attempted to contact him according
to biographer Charles casillo and the
anonymous letters signed tearful father
are an invention of the novel and film
in 2022 a French DNA researcher
apparently proved that Gifford and
Monroe were related his findings were
broadcast in the documentary Marilyn her
final Secret
Marilyn Monroe's fraught upbringing with
her mother Gladys is represented
primarily by two hellish frightening
sequences early in the film The First is
when Gladys puts young Norma Jean in
their car and attempts to drive into the
Griffith Park Wildfire of 1933. the
second is when she tries to drown her
daughter in the bathtub after the
bathtub incident Gladys is hospitalized
and confined to a mental institution for
the rest of her life Norma Jean after
being cared for by her neighbors for a
short time is dropped off at an
orphanage when she sees her mother again
10 years later Norma Jean has
transformed fully into Maryland and
Gladys in the throes of schizophrenia
doesn't recognize her while these
specific incidents presented here may
not be confirmed both Gladys and her
mother Della Monroe were known to have
violent outbursts related to mental
illness Monroe's earliest years were
mostly spent in the care of family
friends in an incident detailed in J
Randy taraborrelli's book The Secret
Life of Marilyn Monroe Della talked her
way into the home where infant Norma
Jean was living and tried to smother her
with a pillow low later when Norma Jean
was three Gladys attempted to abduct her
by stuffing her in a duffel bag after
Gladys was institutionalized in 1934
Norma Jean was a ward of the state
living in orphanages and Foster homes
before being taken in by family friend
Grace Goddard at age 11.
in blonde Marilyn Monroe's Big Break
comes after years spent as a pinup model
when she's offered an audition for a
studio Mogul referred to as Mr Z played
by David warshovsky stepping into an
intimidating office full of taxidermied
animals Monroe nervously reads her
script in front of a silent Mr Z until
the man steps behind her still without a
word and sexually assaults her later in
the film when she's talking about the
beginning of her career with the
ex-athlete the film's stand-in for
second husband Joe DiMaggio played by
Bobby conavale Marilyn flashes back to
this moment and simply tells him that
she was quote discovered Mr Z is by all
accounts in avatar for 20th Century Fox
Head Daryl F zanek Monroe was under
contract at Fox for much of her film
career and she and zanik are known to
have had a difficult working
relationship Monroe bristled at the dumb
blonde role she was regularly offered
while he considered her simply that a
dumb blonde and while tales of the
casting couch were common in Hollywood
both then and now according to biography
for Anthony Summers there's no evidence
that zanik assaulted Monroe in this
manner as to her being discovered Fox's
official story was that she'd been
discovered while babysitting for a
casting director initially hiding the
fact that she'd been a pinup and
occasional nude model for years before
being cast in her first film
in blonde Marilyn Monroe is seen in 1951
auditioning for the Richard Widmark
Thriller don't bother to knock in a
tight close-up mimicking the angle of
the screen Test's camera Monroe gives an
intense soul-bearing monologue the role
is uncomfortably close to her own life a
woman whose mother was abusive and whose
father had abandoned her long ago after
she's done she pleads for another chance
but is taken away by her manager the
crew is dumbfounded by what they saw as
a terrible performance but the director
is captivated by her looks the scene
treats Monroe as if she's an unknown at
this time as if she's never stepped in
front of the camera in reality she was a
sensation almost from the moment she
appeared on film in fact the year before
she'd made two of her most notable early
movies All About Eve and John Houston's
Noir the asphalt jungle she'd even
weathered a scandal involving nude
photos she'd posed for in 1949. as for
don't bother to knock the film received
mixed reviews but Monroe's performance
was singled out for praise with variety
writing Marilyn Monroe gives an
excellent account of herself in a
strictly dramatic attic role
Marilyn Monroe was romantically linked
to any number of Hollywood luminaries in
the early 1950s before her relationship
with Joe DiMaggio including Marlon
Brando and director Elia Kazan the film
represents this time in her life by
focusing on an unconventional romance
with two Show Business science Charlie
Chaplin Jr nicknamed Cass and Edward G
Robinson Jr known as Eddie G Monroe
envies them because everyone in the
world knows who their fathers are while
cassinetti G Envy her for the fact that
she's an orphan and can make herself
into anything she wishes
we're Juniors of men who never wanted us
the three do everything together and
when Monroe gets pregnant they celebrate
as a group Monroe was involved with
chaplain in real life for a short time
according to biographer Anthony Summers
but the relationship apparently came to
an end after she had an affair with
Chaplin's Brother Robinson isn't known
to have dated Monroe or chaplain either
separately or in the polyamorous Triad
the film depicts the film also has
chaplain dying before Monroe and in a
posthumous communication tour he reveals
that he was the author of all the
letters her father wrote to her in real
life chaplain would outlive Monroe by
six years dying in 1968 at age 42. in
the film Marilyn Monroe boxed at her
contracted 500 a week salary for
appearing in Howard Hawk's musical
Gentlemen Prefer Blondes when she learns
that co-star Jane Russell is making one
hundred thousand dollars after all she's
the blonde of the title and I'm playing
the blonde in gentleman Prefer Blondes
that's an insult
but there are other complications in
taking the role Beyond money her
pregnancy is a professional barrier and
she also fears that her mother's mental
illness could be hereditary at the
Studio's insistence Monroe decides to
terminate the pregnancy leading to the
first of the film's two graphic abortion
sequences verifying the accuracy of
Monroe's abortions or even if she had
any is difficult it was illegal
Nationwide to terminate a pregnancy in
1953 and the notion that Monroe had
several abortions in the course of her
life was popularized by author Gloria
Steinem in her 1986 biography Marilyn
Norma Jean however it is known that
Monroe was paid considerably less for
her star-making role in Gentlemen Prefer
Blondes it was one of many small insults
during her time under the thumb of Daryl
F zanek and a large part of her
motivation to break her contract with
Fox and start her own production company
this however is a chapter in her life
that the film ignores along with any
other sense that Monroe was an active
participant in her career after Marilyn
Monroe's abuse of marriage to the
ex-athlete ends in divorce she treats to
New York City to study acting when the
playwright the films stand in for Arthur
Miller played by Adrian Brody sees her
in a reading of one of his plays he
assumes that she's been cast because the
director is in love with her but as the
lights come up after the reading the
playwright is in tears at her
performance Monroe impresses him with
how well-read she is while she connects
to his gentle intellectualism a complete
opposite of the prudish brutality of the
ex-athlete the two marry in 1956 the
film frames the play reading as the
first time they meet the playwright has
heard of her obviously but they don't
know each other in real life Miller and
Monroe met in Los Angeles in 1950 the
two would correspond off and on over the
years until reconnecting in New York in
1955 while Monroe was studying at the
Actors Studio and managing her own
production company Miller however was
married at the time of their Affair and
under investigation by the House
Un-American Activities Committee for
alleged communist affiliations there is
nothing politician won't stoop to if it
means some listening Forum or some power
Monroe stood by him through both his
divorce and his legal troubles none of
which is given any space in Andrew
Dominic's film
the affair between Marilyn Monroe and
John F Kennedy has always been the stuff
of second-hand reports and urban legends
rather than established fact according
to Donald's photos comprehensive 1993
biography of Monroe the two were only
ever seen in public together four times
biographer Anthony Summers on the other
hand treats it very much as a fact that
she was involved with both JFK and his
brother Robert that her final days were
preoccupied with thoughts of both men
and that JFK may have even visited her
in California shortly before her death
the film dramatizes her alleged
relationship with Kennedy via a
nightmarish sequence in which an
inebriated Monroe is escorted off an
airplane by Secret Service agents
literally dragged through the back
hallways of a New York Hotel she's then
placed in the president's hotel room
where she's essentially forced to do
something against her will afterwards
she's escorted right back out by secret
service that nightmare feeling continues
in a later scene where she dreams of men
kidnapping her in the middle of the
night and forcibly removing what were to
assume is her baby with the president
the second of the film's explicit and
disturbing abortion scenes
during blonde it's 1962 and Marilyn
Monroe receives a call from Eddie G with
the sad news that Cass has died he
informs her that Cass left her something
and to watch out for a delivery when
that delivery comes it's an old stuffed
tiger like the one she had as a girl
along with a note containing a terrible
cruel confession Cass was the one
writing letters to her claiming to be
her father the Revelation sends Monroe
into a talespin of Anguish standing by
the pool of her Hollywood home she
swallows dozens of pills one after the
other she strips off her clothes and
climbs into bed takes the phone off the
hook and passes out as she slowly dies
she has a vision of the man she thought
was her father his face beckoning her
from the heavens however Monroe knew who
her father was and neither Cass nor
anyone else wrote her letters like that
the entire sequence other than the
condition Monroe's body was found in is
a flight of fancy so what might have
happened the Los Angeles coroner at the
time ruled her death a probable suicide
due to the sheer amount of barbiturates
she'd ingested yet her personal
correspondence from that time collected
and published in 2010 as the book
fragments shows a side of her that
finally felt on firm ground leading
Credence to the idea that her death was
accidental if you or anyone you know has
been a victim of sexual assault help is
available visit the rape abuse and
incest National Network website or
contact Reigns National helpline at
1-800-656-hope 4673
[Music]